[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: OK.
So we're going to continue
our discussion of--
is it 1M or 2?
It's 1.
Of the Riemann integral, which,
remember, from the discussion
at the end of the
last lecture, is
a theory of area underneath
the graph of a function.
So what is that theory?
The theory is built
up as follows.
Given a continuous function f--
so this is just a refresher
on the definitions
I introduced last time--
a partition is just
points between--
just breaking up the interval
from a to b into points,
into little subintervals, with
the norm of this partition
being the length of the
longest subinterval [INAUDIBLE]
which we refer to as a tag.
It's just a set
of points with one
lying in each of
these subintervals--
so for me, let's take them
all to be the right endpoint
of these intervals--
and then associated to a
tagged partition, which
is a pair, x and [? xe. ?]
We associated a Riemann sum,
which is f evaluated at
these points times the length
of the interval.
So if we draw the graph
of a function f and--
say, in this picture--
this number this
Riemann sum would then
be equal to the area of
these three boxes here.
OK?
And so our theory of
Riemann integration,
or our theory of the area
underneath the curve,
is built on the following
goal, which is to show that,
as these partitions
get finer and finer,
as the norm of these
partitions goes to 0,
these Riemann sums should
converge to some number.
And that number, which we call
the Riemann integral of f,
we interpret as the area
underneath the graph of f.
So the first goal--
the main goal, really,
to start off with--
is to show that this
is a reasonable--
that this is actually true that,
these Riemann sums do, in fact,
converge to some
number as they become
finer and finer for a
given continuous function.
So that is the
main theorem, which
I think is going to be the
main thing that we prove today.
So theorem of the
Riemann integral,
which is the following--
let f be a continuous
function from a b to r--
which, remember,
this is the notation
we used from last time.
Let me move my
picture over here.
Then there exists a
unique real number, which
we denote as the usual
symbol, integral a b f
of x dx with the
following property--
for every sequence
of partitions xr cr,
such that the norm of these
partitions is going to 0 as r
goes to infinity-- so
these partitions are
getting finer and finer
if the norm is going to 0.
Remember, the norm is the length
of the longest subinterval
I have.
So for all sequence
of partitions,
with norms converging
to 0, we have
that the limit of
the Riemann sums
exists and equals
this number, which
we refer to as the
Riemann integral of f.
OK?
So there's a lot to unpack here.
First off, what this
number, integral from a b
to f of x dx-- this
property that it has is,
no matter what
sequence of partitions
you take, as long as they're
becoming finer and finer,
this limit actually exist,
and it equals the same number.
It equals this number,
integral a b f of x dx.
So I could take two different
sequences of partitions
becoming finer and finer,
look at the Riemann sums,
and those two sequences
of Riemann sums converge,
and they converge
to the same number--
again, which we denote
by integral a b f
of x dx, the Riemann
integral of f.
And so it's this
number, which we
interpret as the area
underneath the graph of f.
OK?
All right, so our main goal for
today is to prove this theorem.
So first off, there's two
parts of the statement here.
There exists a
unique real number,
which we denoted by
that with this property.
Uniqueness is immediate.
If I have two real
numbers, such that,
for all sequence of partitions
with norm going to 0,
the limit of the
Riemann sums equals
that limit, well, limits
of sequences are unique,
and therefore, those two
numbers have to be the same.
So uniqueness is clear.
It's really the existence
part that we have to prove,
that there exists a
real number so that,
no matter what sequence
of partitions we take,
the corresponding Riemann
sums converges to 0--
as long as they become--
the partitions become
finer and finer.
OK?
OK.
Now, we're not going to
prove this theorem just yet.
We need some facts that
will be used in the proof,
so we're going to
put off proving
this theorem for a few
minutes and first prove
some necessary facts.
So let me first define a useful
metric or number associated
to-- or function associated to
a continuous function called
the modulus of continuity.
So for f continuous
function and eta positive,
we define the modulus
continuity omega f of eta--
this is equal to the supremum of
f of x minus f of y [INAUDIBLE]
absolute value, such that the
absolute value of x minus y
is less than or equal
to [? eta. ?] OK?
So what does this modulus
of continuity measure?
It measures, given-- if I
take any two points less than
or equal to eta in distance,
and I look f of x minus f of y
in absolute value, and
take the sup over all that,
that gives me the
modulus of continuity.
Now, for example, let's
do the simplest example
possible, f of x
equals ax plus b.
Then what do we get?
f of x minus f of y--
this is equal to
a times x minus y.
So if x minus y is less
than or equal to eta,
we get that f of x minus
f of y in absolute value
is less than or equal to--
well, it's equal to
a times x minus y
is less than or
equal to a times eta.
Right?
And therefore, absolute
value of a times eta
is an upper bound for this
set for this function.
And it's also achieved.
If I take absolute value
of x minus y equal to eta,
then this will be equality.
So what I'm saying is
that, for this example,
for f equals ax plus b,
the modulus of continuity
is equal to a absolute
value of a times eta.
OK.
Now, something to note here is
that, for this guy right here,
as eta goes to 0, the modulus
of continuity goes to 0 as well.
And this is not special
to this function.
In fact, it's true for
all continuous functions.
So let me state the
theorem and then give you
an interpretation of it.
So let me call this theorem 1.
So for all f continuous on the
closed and bounded interval
in a, b, limit as eta goes to
0 of omega f of eta equals 0.
OK.
So let me make one
more comment here.
Maybe this will also--
just to connect to
something we did
earlier, which
follows immediately
from the definition of this
guy, that for all x and y,
this is true.
OK?
And therefore, you
should think of,
I'm trying to make this small,
then the modulus of continuity
is something that controls
how close f of x and f of y
are together.
So somehow continuity is
controlled by this function,
the modulus of continuity.
So if this goes to 0, then--
as this goes to
0, this goes to 0,
then somehow I'm saying
f of x and f of y
are very close together.
So again, the
modulus of continuity
is a way of measuring
continuity of a function.
That's one way to think of it.
All right, so let's prove this.
This is a limited statement,
and what we're going to do
is we'll just prove it
the old-fashioned way.
Let epsilon be positive.
What do we know
about functions which
are continuous on a closed
and bounded interval?
While, they're also
uniformly continuous.
So since f is continuous on this
closed and bounded interval,
f is uniformly continuous.
This means that there
exists delta 0 positive,
such that, for all x and y,
x and y less than delta 0
implies that f of x minus
f of y is less than--
let me put epsilon over 2.
I'm going to give myself
a little space here.
OK?
So just to recall,
what we're trying
to do here in terms of the
definition of what this means--
we're trying to show that,
for all epsilon positive,
there exists delta positive,
such that, for all eta--
eta's actually a positive
number here, so--
implies omega of eta
is less than epsilon.
OK?
OK.
All right, so this is what
we're trying to prove.
We know that, for a
continuous function,
it's uniformly continuous,
and therefore, there exists
is delta 0 so that, when x
minus y is less than delta 0,
f of x minus f of y is less
than epsilon over 2 for all
x, y in the interval.
OK?
So basically, I'm
going to choose delta
to be this delta 0, the
delta I need for this.
And now let me
show that it works.
Suppose eta is less than delta,
which, remember, is delta 0.
Then, if x minus y
is less than eta--
which, again, is less than--
less than or equal to eta,
which is less than delta 0--
I get that f of x minus f of
y is less than epsilon over 2.
Basically, I just rewrote
what I had right there.
And therefore, this implies
that epsilon over 2 is an upper
bound for the set f of x
minus f of y, x minus y,
which is less than eta, which
implies that the supremum
of this set-- which
is, by definition--
so I'm just going to
put brackets here,
and I hope that's clear that
I'm referring to this set
here when I put that here--
that the supremum
of this set has
to be less than or equal
to this upper bound, which
is less than epsilon.
OK?
So we've proven that, if
eta is less than delta,
then the modulus of
continuity of f--
of eta is less than epsilon.
And therefore, this is
what we wanted to prove.
OK.
All right, so that's
one fact that I need,
that this modulus of
continuity-- which, remember,
is the supremum of the
difference of f of x and f
of y, as long as x and
y are bounded by eta--
that this converges
to 0 as eta converges
to 0 for all
continuous functions.
OK?
And this is key in showing that
the Riemann integral exists
for continuous functions.
So theorem two is the following.
So this is going to
tell us how two Riemann
sums are comparable
if one partition is
finer than the other.
So if I have two tagged
partitions of a, b,
such that x prime
is a subset of x--
so this means that x prime--
so this is a partition--
a breakup of a, b--
that contains all the
points of x and more.
OK?
So it's a finer partition.
And we refer to x prime as a
refinement of the partition x.
All right, so we
have two partitions.
One is finer than the other,
and a continuous function f.
Then we can estimate the
difference in the Riemann sums.
This is less than or equal
to the modulus of continuity
of f evaluated at the
norm of the courser
partition times the
length of the interval.
OK?
OK, so this says, as long as--
one way to think about it is,
if the partition x is very fine,
and then I take a finer
partition, that's not
going to change the
Riemann sum too much,
because remember,
this is converging
to 0 as the norm of the
partition-- how fine it is,
or you can think how coarse
it is-- is going to 0.
OK, so the idea is very simple.
It's just going to take me a
little bit just to write down.
Like I said, this partition
being contained in the other
means this partition has all the
points in x and then some more.
We're going to break
these partitions up into--
or at least this
one up into parts
where it's points in x and
then plus the extra one.
So for k equals 1 to n--
so let me draw a picture
first, and then I'll
define the concepts that I have.
So here we have the
partition points of x.
OK?
And above I'm going
to write now--
I used to write
[? xe, ?] but I'm
going to write the
partition points
corresponding to x prime.
So this should be x prime sub
l for some l, because remember,
[INAUDIBLE] this one is
contained in the other.
So this partition point will
be x prime sub l for some l.
And then I'll have
some other ones,
and so on, until I
reach the last partition
point from x prime,
which is contained
in this subinterval
from the partition x.
OK?
So I let y with a k upper--
this is equal to the partition
x sub k minus 1 equals x prime l
plus 1, until I get to
some partition point x sub
m, which equals x sub k.
OK?
So this is just a part of the
partition x prime, contained
in this subinterval, where
these are partition points in x.
And then I'm going
to write eta k.
This will be the tags that
come with these points.
OK.
So what I want to
draw attention to is
that the tagged partition
x, prime c prime--
this is equal to let
me write it this way.
Since these are sets
what I mean by--
let me write it as the union
of the tagged partitions.
And also, this eta has nothing
to do with the eta from before.
All right?
I'm just using this as notation.
So the full partition of
x prime and [INAUDIBLE]
prime tagged partition is equal
to the union of these smaller
partitions of xk minus 1 and
xk as k runs from 1 to k.
OK?
I hope that's clear.
All right.
All right, so now let's compare
the part of the agreement
Riemann for x [? xe ?]
on this interval.
So remember, somewhere
sitting in here
is the tag corresponding to
the k-th tag for this guy.
Let's compare it to the
part of the Riemann sum
for the x prime [? xe ?] prime
also coming from this interval.
OK.
In fact, let me
make one more remark
that, since this
tagged partition is
equal to the union of
these tagged partitions,
this implies that
the Riemann sum
corresponding to
this tagged partition
is equal to the sum
of the Riemann sums
corresponding to these
partitions of these intervals,
xk minus 1 and xk.
All right?
So these are not
partitions of a, b,
but they are partitions
of xk minus 1 and xk.
All right.
So I hope all this is clear.
Again, I'm just breaking this
Riemann sum up into parts where
now I'm looking at what's
happening between each
of the partition
points x sub k minus 1
and x sub k coming from the
original courser partition x.
All right?
Now we compute.
So this is a part
of the Riemann sum
of x [? xe ?] from this interval
minus the part of the agreement
some for x prime [? xe ?] prime
coming from this interval.
Now, this is equal
to f of [? xe ?] k.
And so let me just
rewrite this sum here.
x sub k minus x sub
k minus 1-- this
is equal to sum from k equals,
let's say, j equals l plus 1
to m x prime sub j minus
[? x of ?] [INAUDIBLE] minus 1.
So of the smaller ones
that are in there,
this is just a telescoping sum.
So all I pick up is x sub j
prime sub m, which is x sub k,
minus the first one, which
is x sub-- x prime sub l,
which is x sub k
minus 1, minus--
and then this is, by definition,
equal to j equals l plus 1
[INAUDIBLE] f of prime j,
x prime j minus x minus 1--
and then a absolute value
sign on the outside.
And then I combine
these two, and--
this is equal to sum from
j equals l plus 1 to k of k
minus j times x prime j
minus x prime j minus 1--
absolute value.
Now, by the triangle inequality,
the absolute value of the sum
is less than or equal to the
sum of the absolute value.
So save myself writing--
I'm going to bring the
absolute values inside.
OK.
Now, [? xe ?] sub
k and xe sub j--
they're both in the interval
x sub k, x sub k minus 1.
And by what I wrote up
there, another way of--
or what follows simply
from the definition
of the modulus of continuity--
this is less than or equal
to omega f of x
sub k [? x sub ?]
k minus 1 times x times j
minus x prime j minus 1.
And this equals-- now,
this doesn't depend on j,
so this is, again just
a telescoping sum.
So I just pick up times x--
so that's for one piece,
and now I just add them up.
Then I look at--
and so like I said, this is
equal to the sum of these terms
that look like this
from k equals 1 to n.
This is equal to the sum
of terms like this from k
equals 1 to n.
That's what I wrote up there.
And so if I apply the
triangle inequality,
this is less than or equal to
sum from k equals 1 to n of f
of [? xe ?] k times xk minus
xk minus 1 minus s [? sub ?] f
eta, which--
I have this estimate right here.
I've already estimated--
so started off with this.
And I showed it was less
than or equal to this.
So now let me stick that
estimate into here--
less than or equal to sum
from k equals 1 to n omega
f of xk minus xk minus 1
times xk minus xk minus 1.
So another thing
which you should
notice about the
modulus of continuity
is, if I have something here
and then something bigger,
this set gets bigger,
and therefore, this sup
gets bigger.
So another property of
the modulus of continuity
is that it's increasing.
This just follows from
looking at the definition.
There's more points
to take a sup over
f this thing gets bigger.
So implies-- OK?
So all of these lengths of
these subintervals, the distance
between partition
points, those are all
bounded by the norm of the
partition, the biggest one.
So this is less than or equal to
sum from k equals 1 to n omega
f of norm of x times
xk minus xk minus 1.
And now, this
doesn't depend on k,
so I just pick up the
sum from k equals 1 to n
of this, which is
a telescoping sum.
All I pick up is x sub n minus x
sub 0, which is just b minus a,
which is the estimate
we wanted to prove.
OK?
OK, so now I'm going to do
something that's sacrilegious,
as far as board work goes.
And I'm going to
erase this board
and prove the next
theorem on it, because I
want to keep what I prove--
or at least a statement
of what I prove around
for when we finally tackled
the proof of the existence
of the Riemann integral.
So this is in
permanent form on--
in digital form, and
also in the notes.
Also, I should mention, we're
not following the textbook now.
So you have to read the lecture
notes or watch the lecture.
All right, so this
theorem here, theorem two,
allowed us to compare
two Riemann sums,
as long as one partition
is finer than the other.
But there's a simple
trick which we can now
use to prove how to compare any
two Riemann sums for any two
partitions.
So we have the
following, theorem three.
If xc and-- now they're
any tagged partitions--
and f is a continuous
function, then
I look at the Riemann
sum of this guy
and then compare it to the
Riemann sum of the other guy.
This is less than or equal
to the modulus of continuity
evaluated at the first partition
plus modulus of continuity
applied to the second
partition times the length
of the interval.
OK?
What does this say?
This says that, if I take
two very fine partitions,
so that the norms
are very small,
and therefore, the modulus
of continuity evaluated
at these norms a
small-- remember,
the modulus of continuity
converges to 0 as the argument
goes to 0.
So if I take two
very fine partitions,
then the Riemann sums
are very close together.
The Riemann sums barely change.
And so now we have some hope to
see that sequences of Riemann
sum do, in fact, converge.
OK, so how do we prove this?
It's a simple trick using
the previous theorem
to find a third partition
to be the common refinement
of these two.
So take this partition and
union it with the second one,
and take a new set of tags to
be the union of the two tags.
So all the partition
points of x and x prime--
I throw them together to get a
new partition, x double prime--
and then the tags as well.
Then x-- backwards--
this new partition
is finer than x.
It's finer than x prime.
And therefore, by
theorem two, we
have this estimate
which we can use.
So if I look at the difference
of the Riemann sums,
and I add and subtract the
Riemann sum corresponding to x
double prime and
[? xe ?] double prime,
and then I use the
triangle inequality--
so I'm doing two steps here--
so add and subtract the
Riemann sum corresponding to--
and then apply the
triangle inequality.
For both of these,
I can now insert
this estimate here from
theorem two, where--
what's the modulus of
continuity being evaluated at?
It's being evaluated at
the courser partition.
So x double prime is contained
in x, so this is less than
or equal to the modulus
of continuity evaluated
at x prime times b minus a.
And then, for this one, x prime
is coarser than x double prime.
This one is contained
in x prime-- so
plus the modulus of continuity
evaluated at x prime times b
minus a.
And that's what we
wanted to prove.
OK.
All right, so now
we're in a position
to prove this theorem
of the Riemann integral.
And so what we're going
to do is we're first
going to come up with
a candidate for what
the integral could be.
And then we're going to
show that's the actual--
that that candidate
satisfies the conclusion--
or this property
that, no matter what
partition I take, with
norms converging to 0,
the Riemann sums
converge to this number.
OK?
So first we have to come
up with a candidate number.
All right.
So first, take any--
so let's fix some partition of--
for the Greek letter aficionados
out there, this is zeta.
Let this be a partition of
a, b with norm converting
to 0 as r goes to infinity.
You can always come up
with some partition.
So this [INAUDIBLE] tagged.
You can always come up with
one, at least one partition--
or sequence of partitions.
So this is [? be a ?]
sequence of tagged partitions.
OK, now this is finally right.
So you can always come
up with a sequence
of tagged partitions of a, b
with the norms converging to 0.
Take the first one to be
just the whole interval--
so just left endpoint,
right endpoint.
Next one add-- the midpoint.
That's now three
partition points.
Now add the midpoint of the
previous two intervals you had.
Now add the midpoint
of the intervals
you had before, and
so on, and that'll
build up a sequence of
partitions with norm
converging to 0.
So I have this fixed
sequence of tag partitions,
and I claim that the Riemann
sums converge for this guy.
All right?
So claim one-- the
sequence of sums--
this is a sequence
of numbers now--
OK.
So it converges to some number.
We're going to prove this
by showing its Cauchy.
Remember, Cauchy sequences of
real numbers always converge.
That's this completeness
property of the real numbers.
OK.
So there's no other
way to do this.
Then, using the definition--
the epsilon [? m ?] definition--
so let epsilon be positive.
So by theorem one, there
exists a delta positive,
such that if eta is
less than delta--
I should say-- so we know that
the modulus of continuity for f
converges to 0 as eta goes to 0.
So for all eta less than
delta, omega f of eta
is less than epsilon
over 2 times B minus a.
OK?
Let me put a star by this guy.
Now, since the norms of
these partitions is--
are converging to 0, there
exists natural number m0 such
that, for all r bigger
than or equal m0,
the norm is less than delta.
OK.
And thus, for all r bigger
than or equal to m0,
if I look at the modulus
of continuity evaluated
at this norm of this partition--
so the norm of this partition
is less than delta.
And if I stick that into
the modulus of continuity,
anything I stick into the
modulus of continuity which is
less than delta--
which this is--
I should be less than epsilon
over 2 times b minus a.
So really, this
is the one I want
to star, maybe not this one.
I am using this one to get it,
but this is the key point here.
OK.
So here we're just using the
fact that modulus of continuity
converges to 0 as the
argument converges to 0,
and that the norms
are converging to 0.
OK?
OK.
So [? to show something's ?]
Cauchy, we
have to now choose m.
I'm going to choose m to be m0.
[INAUDIBLE] r, r prime bigger
than or equal to m-- which,
remember, we've chosen to m0.
We have that the absolute
value of s of f xr--
r, minus the Riemann
sum, now with r prime--
absolute value.
This is by theorem three,
which we proved over there--
is bounded by the sum of
the modulus of continuities
evaluated at the
norms times b minus a.
And now r and r prime are bigger
than or equal to m0, and so
by star--
so this line here.
This is by theorem three.
But now, by star,
by our choice of m0,
this is less than
epsilon over 2 times
b minus a plus epsilon over
2 b minus a times b minus a.
This is now by star,
which equals epsilon.
And therefore, this
sequence of Riemann
sums with respect to this
one sequence converges.
OK?
And so we've proven the claim.
Let me call the limit of
this sequence something.
I'm going to call it L. In fact,
let's call it I for integral.
Let I be limit as r
goes to infinity of--
oh, I messed up my
notation earlier.
Sorry about that.
The y's, and, x's and [? xe's ?]
should have been y's and zetas.
So that should have been
y, zeta, y, zeta, and then
y here, y here.
OK?
Now that's right.
So I is defined to be
the limit of these guys.
So now we have to do
one last thing in order
to prove the theorem.
I have this number I, and I
claim now that I satisfies
the properties of
the theorem-- namely,
that if I take any
sequence of Riemann sums--
or any sequence of
tagged partitions
and take the Riemann
sums, that converges to I.
We've just shown that there
is one that converges to.
That's how I is defined.
We took one partition--
sequence of tagged partitions
and showed that the Riemann
sums converge to some
number I. So this number
I depends on the partition,
which I chose in the beginning.
Now we want to show
that this I, in fact,
has that property,
that no matter
what partition--
sequence of partitions
I take the Riemann
sums converge to I.
So that's the second
and last thing I need
to do to prove this theorem.
So claim-- let x be now any
sequence of tagged partitions,
which are becoming
finer and finer-- so
with the norm converging to 0.
Then I want to show
that limit as r
goes to infinity
of the Riemann sums
corresponding to this
sequence of partial sums--
[INAUDIBLE] partial sums--
this sequence of partitions
exists, and equals
this number I,
which I obtained from this
one sequence of partitions.
So once I've proven
this [INAUDIBLE]
once I've proven
this, then I'm done.
OK?
This number I is therefore--
satisfies that property
that, no matter what sequence
of partitions I
take, the sequence
of Riemann sums with
respect to these partitions
converges to that number.
Of course, here
I'm calling it I,
but we denoted by the integral
from a, b of f of x dx.
So to prove this is
not too difficult using
what we have on the board.
So remember, I is the limit with
respect to this one sequence
of partitions, and now we
have an arbitrary sequence
of partitions, which we want to
show the Riemann sums converge
to this number as well.
So with y sub r-- or yr and zeta
r, the partitions from before,
we have--
by the triangle
inequality, if I look
at the Riemann sum with
respect to this arbitrary
partition now--
subtract I-- I want to
show this convergence to 0,
so I'm just going to
bound this by something
that converges to 0.
And then, by the usual argument
with the squeeze theorem,
that implies this
thing converges to 0.
So adding and subtracting
the Riemann sum associated
to the partition y and zetas--
this is less than or equal to
in the triangle inequality,
minus sf of
[INAUDIBLE] plus now--
minus I.
And so I'm almost there.
This thing now-- I
use theorem three.
So this is less
than or equal to--
times b minus a plus--
s sub f of i sub r minus I. OK?
The norm of the x sub r--
this is converging to 0.
So this converges to--
since the modulus of continuity
goes to 0 as the argument goes
to 0, this goes to 0, plus--
remember, the same
thing for this guy--
this also converges to 0, plus--
how did we define I?
It was defined as the limit of
the Riemann sums corresponding
to this first fixed partition.
And therefore, this
thing in absolute value
converges to 0 as r
convergence is to infinity.
All right, so the absolute
value of this thing,
this Riemann sum, minus I is
bounded by something converging
to 0 as r goes to infinity.
And therefore, by
the squeeze theorem,
we conclude that the limit
as r goes to infinity of s--
so in other words, no matter
what sequence of partitions
we take, with norms
converging to 0,
the Riemann sums converge
to this same number I.
And that's the end of the proof.
OK.
It took a lot of
work to do this.
This is the work
of Raymond, so--
who was one of the greatest
mathematicians of all time.
Weierstrass was definitely
one of the greatest analysts
of all time.
Riemann, just as a
mathematician in general,
was one of the
greatest of all time.
He not only did analysis--
he applied analysis
to number theory.
This is the content of the
famous Riemann hypothesis,
which maybe you've
heard about, which
is worth a million dollars--
says something about the zeros
of a certain function, which
then gives you information
about prime numbers.
And he also had
deep contributions
to the foundations of geometry--
or I should say the foundations
of differential geometry--
but truly some deep
stuff going on.
All right, so now we have this
notion of a "remand integral.
It's this no integral f of
x, which has this property.
No matter what
sequence of partitions
I take, with norms
converging to 0,
the partial sums
converge to this number.
So I'm often going to denote--
so if you like, this is some
alternative notation I'll use.
Instead of writing f
of x dx, I may just
write integral a, b, f.
So this definition of the
Riemann integral looks
terrifying if you want to
actually try and compute it.
And it is.
So that's the miracle of
the fundamental theorem
of calculus is that it gives
us a way to compute it.
And that's why I'm not doing
any examples of computing it
right now.
But we can still learn about
some properties of the Riemann
integral without that to start.
So now we're moving on to some
properties of the integral.
And the first is that it--
so this is a limiting process,
but this limiting process
is linear in f.
If I look at Riemann sums
of, let's say, f plus g,
that's equal to the Riemann sum
of f plus the Riemann sum of g.
And therefore, since
integration is a limit of this--
of Riemann sums,
then integration
should also be linear as well.
And that's the first
theorem is the linearity
of the Riemann sum,
Riemann integration--
f and g are a, b.
And alpha is in R.
So first off, alpha f plus
g-- that's going to be--
so that should not be in a, b.
This should be a continuous--
it's the end of a long day, OK?
So sorry if I'm losing a little
steam here towards the end.
Anyways, alpha f plus g,
if f and g are continuous--
this is a continuous
function as well,
so its integral is meaningful.
And its integral is equal to
alpha times the integral f
plus the integral of g.
OK?
So what's the proof?
The proof is basically
what I said right
before I stated the theorem,
that Riemann sums are
linear in the function.
And then we just take a limit.
Let's take a sequence
of tagged partitions
with norms converting to
0 as r goes to infinity.
Then, if I look at the
Riemann sum associated
to alpha f plus g, it is easy to
see from the definition, right?
This is a sum from k
equals 1 to [? in-- ?]
so this is easy to
see that this is
equal to alpha times
the Riemann some
associated to f plus that guy.
And now I just take a limit--
so take the limit as
r goes to infinity.
The left-hand side converges
to the Riemann integral
of alpha f plus g.
The limit as r goes to
infinity converges to--
because we know limits
respect linear operations,
the limit of the
right-hand side is
going to be alpha times
the limit plus the limit.
And therefore, this is equal
to alpha times integral a, b,
f plus integral a, b, g.
OK.
So like differentiation,
it's also
what one would call
a linear operator.
It takes a function and
spits something out,
but does it in a linear way.
So for us, it takes
a continuous function
and spits out a real
number in a linear way.
The integral of
alpha f plus g is
equal to alpha times f plus g.
Just like differentiation, the
derivative of alpha f plus g
if everything's
differentiable, is
equal to alpha times
the derivative of f
plus the derivative of g.
But Riemann integration,
the Riemann integral,
or integration in general,
is in some sense--
I don't want to say
it's not miraculous.
It still is a bit
of a miracle that it
exists for all
continuous functions,
but it's not as
destructive an operator
as taking the
derivative, if you take
as your baseline
continuous functions.
Last lecture we constructed
a continuous function which
is differentiable nowhere.
So with differentiation, you
can take a continuous function
and not be able to take
its derivative anywhere.
Well, with integration,
if you start off
with a continuous function, you
can always take it's integral.
So somehow integration is a
much more smoother process
than differentiation.
All right, so I think
we'll stop there.